Hollywood actor do you think George
looks like oh [ __ ] here we go
Oh Rosenbaum decided I for who it was oh
I remember huh
Ed Begley Young that's closer to the
truth okay read the latest fan art I saw
I looked kind of like Wolf Blitzer
oh yeah a very different view of myself
that other people see I think I'm like a
really cool guy really urbane really
like I think I like walking down the
street I'm like Clint Eastwood like a
badass then I see what people see when
they look at me and I'm like they look
they're just scared I'm going to talk to
him about stamp collecting yeah I just
you know what though you're a good dude
and always remember that no really I'll
be I'm gonna be honest with you look at
me right now man yoga dude and you know
how I remember you when I was at maker
and they were giving me producers think
what about George I'm like nah and right
because you wanted to be my guy and for
a little bit I was like a little bit
hesitant but you won me over with your
enthusiasm and I really do love you man
you're good dude you don't look like
right there and you know that oh my god
my face is covered I've got like
elements do people think that you look
like a guava juice guy on YouTube yeah
no Baba this show yes someone said I do
look like a bug zapper guys like I like
guys like little um like you have
thyroid eyes yeah oh thank you like a
goiter like exophthalmos like this yeah
guava juice is guava juice sometimes it
Bruno Mars but you know never all the
time all the time never doors can be
[ __ ] Brad Pitt I can [ __ ] hear it
over here yeah who have you been have
you have you been mistaken as what Steve
Aoki absolutely there's that not Gilbert
that's that's you right that doesn't
like my sister texted me that yeah
that's you dude
I know
oh my god I'm a youtuber yeah kalila who
have you been mistaken for just most let
me see he says Stanley Tucci but wait
why is daily duty wait it's dude let me
say that one night when I first started
dating her I couldn't sleep and she was
she had to UM
she was getting her breasts done or no
she had him done like she had breast
implants but she had to she couldn't lay
on her back no I couldn't lay on my side
your side so she propped up these
pillows and then she would sleep like
kind of sitting up so one night and then
she also has her iPads and [ __ ] always
on right so I'm slaying next to her
she's propped up asleep and the you know
iPad was shining against her face and
she was wearing no makeup look just like
Stanley to you know and I was like young
family to which though maybe your hair
was pulled back yeah
is that why cuz he's bald yeah was at
very prominent nose yeah and you know I
have very like angular I do there are
moments where I look at the mirror and
I'm not ashamed of it but I haven't
drogyn his features I'm I have angular
features that are a little like boyish
but I don't think it makes me
unattractive like I like it I like being
I like looking like I could be a
handsome dude mmm you know what I mean
like I'm not threatened by the idea of
looking like a dude so what yeah but do
I look like a dude no you don't you're
all your beautiful baby and you're the
heart of my life am i light of my heart
[Music]